All right.
That's my cue.
What's up, everybody?
Thanks for coming.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
Web Components!
It's going to change
everything you know.
Well, maybe just a few things.
But the field is open.
That's the web development.
It's open to you, to
use Web Components.
My name is Eric Bidelman.
So let me turn my clicker on.
I work on the Chrome team.
Feel free to follow me
on Twitter or Google+.
We probably won't have
time for questions.
I've run this a number
of times, and I always
end up at 45, exactly.
But feel free to
shoot me questions
there or ask me questions
at the end of the show.
I'm happy to answer stuff.
I've been focused on Web
Components for a couple years
now, because I really do
think it's a fundamentally
different way to
develop for the web.
I think it's a really exciting
time to be a web developer.
And so that's why I'm
here, talking to you today.
In this presentation, I want
to focus on three areas.
Let's keep it simple.
The first is the
state of the union.
A couple people asked about
browser vendor support,
where the API is in flight,
as far as other browsers.
I want to catch everyone up,
get us all in the same space,
and kind of get you
thinking about what's
happened in the past year.
A lot has changed.
Second, I want to talk
about what problems
do Web Components
actually solve.
Why am I up here barking at
you guys in the first place?
Why are we adding all this
new stuff to the platform,
if all these libraries and
everything else exists today?
It turns out there's
actually a number of things
that Web Components
really do address.
That's why this stuff is
being baked into the browser.
And the last thing, I
want to get everyone
in the same mental space.
We have to actually
think differently
about how we build apps now,
in the world of Web Components
and Polymer.
So I want to get us
thinking in Web Components.
What does it mean to design
an app, architect an app,
and kind of conceptualize
what that means?
So that's what we're
going to cover.
But first, let's
tell a little story.
So once upon a time, the web
platform looked like this.
The web platform was
kind of a conglomerate
of duct tape and
nails and strings,
and we pieced in some CSS over
time, and maybe some JavaScript
over time.
But it was pretty infant, right?
And it was pretty primitive.
This is all we had at
our disposal, though.
We couldn't build complex apps.
You could drop in a form tag.
Right?
We could build-- that was the
app at the time, was forms.
And over time, what happened is,
of course, yes, we got HTML5.
This is going to cure cancer.
It's going to solve all
the world's problems.
And it certainly did, right?
Well, it didn't do that.
But it addressed
a number of things
that we needed on
the web, right?
Geolocation, local storage,
new semantic tags-- a lot
of great stuff
came through HTML5.
And over the years, we've just
kept building on that, right?
We've kept adding to
the web platforms.
We added media APIs, and
WebGL, and Web Audio,
and all this cool stuff to
make the platform really viable
and really awesome as
a development platform.
But what about us
regular developers?
What about myself?
I write JavaScript, and
I write HTML every day.
But I don't write WebGL code.
I've never written
a shader in my life.
What APIs are the browser
vendors adding on our behalf,
to make us more productive?
And so this is
where this journey
started, now four years ago.
If you go all the way
back in time to 2010,
this is when the Web
Components journey started.
So if you look at the first kind
of tinkering of Web Components,
Dimitri Glazkov, who is one
of the sort of godfathers,
the forefathers,
of Web Components,
sent an email to the public
web apps mailing list and said,
hey, you know, a few of us
have been tinkering around
with ideas about things
we can add to the browser
to make developers
more productive.
So this is actually kind
of telling, at the time.
They identified things
like templating, right?
Every development platform
out there has templating.
Why doesn't the browser have
native templating support?
Shadow DOM-- being
able to abstract things
and encapsulate them and kind
of bring the best practices
of object-oriented
programming to the web--
was identified four
years ago, now.
And things like data binding.
Now, we're not getting
data binding, properly,
as part of Web Components.
But this is something
that Polymer
has built-in and iterated on
top of the Web Components APIs.
So it's been a long journey.
And so what they said, was, hey,
let's take our web platform.
Let's strip it back.
Let's identify the core
APIs, the core primitives
that we need, in order to
make this really productive
for developers.
And this is where the different
specifications came from.
So we have about
four specifications
that make up Web Components
as an umbrella technology.
The really cool thing about
all these different APIs
are that they can be
used totally separately
by themselves.
But when you put
them together, it
allows developers to tweak
and do really amazing things.
And that's what Polymer's doing.
It's having opinion, on
top of Web Components.
But the lowest level
is all standards-based.
So last year, I gave
this presentation
at I/O. It was
called The Tectonic
Shift for Web Development.
We're still shifting.
The stuff is still new.
But it's actually a
really exciting time.
If you look back,
even just a year ago,
a lot has changed since 2013,
when I gave that presentation.
So I probably painted a
picture that said, hey,
the native stuff is in
browsers everywhere.
But it's actually
mainly just in Chrome,
with a couple of APIs
in the nightly build.
So you can see that's what
the partial support means,
in those logos there.
Firefox had landed templates.
They're just starting to
implement custom elements.
Of course, if you
flash forward today,
this matrix is
completely different.
It's completely lit up.
This is a milestone in
web development, you guys.
Chrome 36 is the
first browser to have
all the native APIs
for Web Components.
Opera gets all this stuff
natively because of their use
of Blink.
So that's two browsers
with all this stuff.
Firefox has got templates
and custom elements now,
and the other partial
support for the other APIs
is in their nightly builds.
You can flip that on
with the developer flag
and try that stuff.
Of course, the other
ones, we don't know.
But with the
polyfills of Polymer
that the Polymer team is
kind of building over time,
you get all the support
in all modern browsers,
for all of the APIs.
So as I said, if you want to
follow the progress of Firefox,
they have a master bug for all
the APIs you can check out.
They're heads-down
implementing all this stuff.
Apple decided to
remove Shadow DOM.
Some of you may have seen
this come up on Hacker News.
And I just want to point out,
this was on Valentine's Day.
They broke our heart.
But they said, no, that
was kind of just a joke.
We're actually experimenting
with this stuff
in a branch of WebKit.
And so what happened
was they didn't
have a maintainer
for all the code
base that happened due
to the WebKit Blink fork.
And so then they
said, hey, we're
actually checking this
stuff out, seriously.
So we're adding stuff back.
Of course, the one that
everyone asks me about is IE.
And IE has hope, OK.
So there's hope here.
If you go to their Platform
Status page, all of the APIs
are under consideration.
So there's hope.
There's promise here.
But just between you and
me-- and I think Matt
alluded to this
before-- we've had
some really productive
conversations with them.
And they're asking
the tough questions,
which means they're taking
and seriously looking
at this stuff.
So that's the browser
landscape for the native stuff.
The other thing that
happened in the past year
is people built stuff.
Developers got excited
about Web Components,
and so they built stuff.
On the Polymer
team, we said, hey,
we might as well
dog-food what we're
building, what we're
really preaching here.
Let's build some stuff.
So we built the Polymer site,
to use Polymer's components
and to use Web Components.
I built chromestatus.com,
which the Blink team uses
to sort of maintain
the features in Chrome
and for developers to see what's
on the landscape of Chrome.
These are really good
examples of just using
small chunks, small
components, and putting them
on a larger site.
Chrome Status is a
database-driven website
that has a component that
talks to the database
and gets the JSON feed.
It renders the versions of
Chrome on the side there.
That's a Component,
responsible for that.
Another thing that happened,
we got wind of early,
a couple weeks ago,
was the WinJS team
started to experiment with
moving some of their controls
and testing some of the WinJS
components as Web Components.
This is really exciting.
And they were starting to
use Polymer to do this.
So if you want to check that
out, that's up on GitHub.
GitHub, in production,
launched custom elements.
This is so cool.
I use GitHub every day.
And I saw this, and I got really
excited, giddy in my pants,
actually.
The local-time tag is something
they're using on the site.
So any time you see
a pre-printed date
on a GitHub page,
that's a Web Component.
Very cool.
They're using Polymer's
polyfills for that.
A little-known fact--
Chrome OS's keyboard,
any time you fire that up,
that's a Web Component.
That's implemented
using Polymer.
And when you kick
back and listen
to tunes or media in
Chrome OS, the media player
is also a Web Component.
It's also a Polymer element.
Very cool stuff.
You'll see some more
examples from Rob.
And Matt showed you some
stuff that we built, also,
in the Polymer team.
So that's where we're at.
That's the state of the
union for Web Components.
I want to focus now on problems
Web Components actually solve.
The grass is greener on the
other side of the field.
So most people see
"BCE," and they say,
"Before the Common Era."
I actually say, "Before
Components Existed."
So there's a time
before Web Components,
in the world of web
development, and there's a time
after Web Components.
And now we're in this sort
of other spectrum here.
And what I mean by this is that
we have to conceptually think
how we build apps differently.
So if you take an example
like the Polymer site, right?
This is the Polymer site.
It's using Components.
But what we've chosen to do is
I stack this in different pieces
that are logical.
So for instance, the top
nav here, this app bar,
is responsible for when
you click that search icon.
It expands and it is responsible
for that functionality.
The center content is
actually a Component, too.
It's a scrolling Component,
that when you scroll the page,
the headers kind of shrink down.
And when you scroll
back, it grows again.
So it adds its event listeners.
It does all that stuff.
It's all baked into
that Component.
And of course, we
have the menu bar.
The menu bar is a
Component that has
sub Components
inside of it, right?
So we can just reuse that on
different parts of the site.
So it's about
compartmentalizing the problem,
no longer thinking
of a site, or an app,
just as a bunch of
JavaScript, a bunch of CSS,
and a bunch of HTML,
just all hoping
it'll kind of work together.
There's a logical
separation now.
So the first API of Web
Components is Custom Elements.
And Custom Elements allows us
to define new HTML and DOM.
And the problem that
it solves is this.
So this is an
actual application.
This is not just a
made-up example, right?
This is Gmail, if you
fire up the DevTools
and you look at the markup
that Gmail's constructed from.
I call this div soup.
There's just a bunch of divs.
It's meaningless.
I don't know what
it's actually saying.
I can't read this
as a developer.
And this application is not
descriptive, whatsoever.
And that's no fault
to the developers.
It's no fault to the Gmail team.
It's basically that HTML
didn't keep up with the times.
It didn't actually allow us
to build the complex apps
that we needed to build.
As the web evolved, as demand
of applications evolved,
HTML got stuck in the
'90s markup, right?
Divs.
Even an example like
a tab strip, right?
Let's take this, just
as a small Component.
Let's create a tab strip.
This is a really
common thing to do.
If you look at that today--
or I should say yesterday,
now that we have
Web Components--
every single version
of every library,
every UI framework out
there, does it differently.
Some use a little bit of HTML.
Some use HTML with JavaScript.
And some just go the
entire JavaScript route.
So it's not so much
HTML versus JavaScript.
The point here that
I'm trying to make
is that these are
all different, right?
Everyone wants to create a tab
strip, but it's all different.
And that's the problem.
The APIs haven't existed.
The Web Components
APIs haven't been there
to make this a standard
way to create a tab strip.
So as a developer,
you come into this.
You have to learn somebody's new
API, calls, to use a tab strip,
or put it on your page.
And that's just no good.
So this is where Custom
Elements come in.
With Custom
Elements, we can just
declaratively define
a new element.
We'll create a
paper-tabs element.
It's got a selected attribute.
It's completely
declarative, and you
know exactly what's going
on in this application.
I can click this around.
This is an example of one
of the material design
elements we have.
You see that property changing.
And that element is firing the
event, the core-activate event.
So we can use querySelector
with this thing.
We can use addEventListener.
The rest of the
platform comes along,
because we're just
creating HTML.
We're just creating DOM.
It's meaningful.
It's maintainable.
I can read this code.
I know what's going on.
And the last thing that I
want to point out-- I'll
talk to this in a few slides--
is that we have a common way
now, with Custom Elements, to
extend other people's stuff.
It's in a common
extension model.
So we can extend
native HTML elements.
You can say, I want this
div to be a super-div.
Or you can say, I want to extend
somebody else's paper-tabs
and create my own version.
Very cool.
So for these type
of slides, I'm going
to show you sort of the vanilla
Web Component way to do things,
the way Polymer
uses the technology,
and what we do to
sugar it, and then
the usage of the Web
Component at the bottom.
So let's go through this.
The way you use
Vanilla Custom Elements
is just
document.registerElement.
And the thing that you give
it is the name of the tag
that you're going to create.
So I'm going to create
the paper-tabs element.
Now, in Polymer,
what we said was,
hey, we really think
declarative is awesome.
It's very powerful.
It's very easy.
So we created a polymer-element.
We created a Custom
Element that allows
you to create Custom Elements.
It's super-meta, but it's
actually really cool.
And it shows you the
power of all this stuff.
You can create an element from
an element, declaratively.
So in Polymer, we say, hey,
declare a polymer-element.
And the name attribute
that you give
it is the tag that
you're creating.
So those are the two
different versions.
But the really nice
thing about this
is it doesn't matter if you're
using vanilla Custom Elements.
It doesn't matter
if you're using
Polymer x-tags or anything else.
The usage, the way
you use this thing,
is exactly the same, right?
You declare paper-tabs
on your page,
or you create it in JavaScript,
and then you're good to go.
I mentioned extension,
a common way
to extend other people's stuff.
In vanilla Web
Components, you can say,
I want to create a super-button.
So you'll give it the
tag you're creating.
And this time, you're
going to inherit
the prototype of the thing that
you want to create it from.
So I'm going to inherit
the HTML button elements
prototype, because I want that
functionality in my JavaScript
prototype.
And I'm extending
the button tag.
In Polymer, we say, hey, we'll
make this declarative, too.
We'll make this a one attribute
that you put on your element,
extends='button.'" So we're
creating a super-button.
And then, again, the usage
of this is exactly the same.
Button is a super-button.
This is a type extension
Custom Element.
We can also extend other
people's Custom Elements, not
just native HTML.
So is this really
better than before?
Great, we can create some HTML.
We can tell the
browser about it.
Is that cool?
Yes.
It's totally cool.
I think it's cool.
But the reason it's
cool is, there's
a couple of really
great examples.
The first is that we're
integrated with the browser
now.
The fact that we're
creating HTML,
and the fact that
we're creating DOM,
is actually really important.
We can take advantage of other
parts of the platform that
are new, like MutationObservers,
querySelector,
and addEventListener.
These are things
that already exist.
We can just reuse those in
the world of Web Components.
We can take advantage of the
browser's parsing and caching
logic.
All that stuff
that's been set up,
and the browser engineers
have worked very hard and long
nights to actually make
really fast for us,
we can take advantage
of that, because we're
integrated at the browser's
lowest level, which is DOM.
That also brings us
interoperability.
So it doesn't matter if a
component is built using x-tags
or if a component is
built using Polymer.
The fact that, again, they all
speak the same language now,
which is DOM, means you can
use these things together.
And you can mix and
match them in your app.
It doesn't matter
who vends them.
You just use the stuff.
So it's interoperable.
I'll admit, I don't
make all my demos
and all my apps accessible.
You guys should.
You, out there in the
live stream, should, too.
But it's actually really cool.
Now we can take advantage
of keyboard stuff
that the browser has.
Focusability, ARIA
roles, all that stuff
that's there for us--
we can build that
into our Custom Elements,
just by default.
And the last one that
I'm super-excited about
is DevTools support.
So first-class
support for tools.
I want to show a video
of this because I really
do think it is that cool.
This is Polymer's site.
And we have this
little tab strip widget
in different places
of the site, where
you can select
kind of a code view
and see a live preview
at the right here.
I'm going to just show
you this in action.
So that's what it does.
Now, the fact that we're
creating HTML and telling
the browser about
this new element
means we're integrated
with the tools.
So I can poke around
in the Elements panel.
I can inspect that, just
using your common inspector.
I can fire up the console.
And I can auto-complete
this element's APIs
and discover its
properties and methods.
So that's really cool.
I can change this thing, right?
You're changing the
tab dynamically,
just by changing that selected
property that the element has.
CSS and HTML work
really well together.
So I can change the styles
in the Styles panel,
and it just updates
itself, right?
So I can tweak and use the
DevTools Save functionality.
So all that really cool stuff
that the DevTools team has been
building-- remote
debugging of the console,
auditing-- all that great stuff,
you can take advantage of now
that you're kind of integrated
at the browser's lowest level.
So first-class Tools support.
Very huge.
The next API is
templates, HTML templates.
And what templates does is
bring proper, native client-side
templating to the browser.
Templates yesterday looked
something like this.
So the way a lot of
libraries and frameworks
do templating is
that they say, hey,
put a bunch of stuff
in a script tag,
and we'll change the MIME type
so the browser doesn't actually
throw that off to the
JavaScript engine.
And so that's great.
But what you actually
put inside is not DOM.
It's just strings.
So we're pushing strings around.
And it feels kind of icky.
The other way that
people do this is they
have a template, a
constructor or something,
and they'll have
a template string.
So it's just you're
scaffolding out using a string.
And then you have
a render method.
So template, render,
template, render.
And so what the Web
Components folks said was,
hey, we should
just bake this in.
Why do every framework and
library do this differently?
So what they brought
us is the template tag.
And the template tag has some
really amazing properties.
So the first is that
anything you put inside of it
is going to be totally inert.
It's not going to do anything
until you clone this template,
until you stamp it out,
until you activate it.
So for instance,
this image in here,
this image.png that I
have in my template,
is not going to make a request.
It's actually not
going to be requested
until I clone this template
and use an instance of it.
So script's not going to run.
Video's not going to play.
It's got a lot of great
inert properties like that.
It's display:none by default.
So I can't actually
see this template.
It's kind of hidden
away in the document.
In fact, you can't even traverse
into it using the DOM APIs.
It's truly a template.
It's out of the
scope of your page.
And the last one is
we're using DOM here.
So this is truly DOM that you're
scaffolding this thing with.
You're not pushing
around strings anymore,
which is really, really good.
You're at the
browser's lowest level.
So the way you do this in
vanilla Web Components,
using template, is just you
drop a template on your page.
And you can scaffold
out markup using markup.
In Polymer, we said, hey,
any time you create a Polymer
element, all the
guts of your element
are going to be
inside of a template.
So you get all that inert
properties that I talked about.
Scripts are not going to
run until an instance is
created of your element.
Now, the other thing
we've done is we've said,
hey, we want to teach
template a couple new tricks.
So we have the outermost
template, which is the thing
that your markup of your
element is created from.
But the inner
templates can do things
like use data binding features.
So you can have an
iterative template
that says, for user in
users, stamp out this markup,
declaratively.
You have conditional templates
and that sort of thing.
So it becomes really powerful.
The entirety of inside
of your Polymer element
can be declarative,
just by using
these features and the
data binding stuff.
The next API, one of the big
daddies of Web Components
is Shadow DOM.
And what Shadow DOM
brings to the table
is DOM and CSS scoping.
If you take anything away
from Shadow DOM today,
or in the future, it's that
it brings composability
and scoping to the web platform.
So we can kind of look
down this little lens
and scope the problem, design
our apps in small chunks,
and have some guarantees
that things are protected.
So in vanilla Shadow DOM, the
way you use this is say, hey,
I have an element.
I want to put some
Shadow DOM behind it
and abstract that stuff
away from the user.
So you call createShadowRoot.
And then you fill the inner
HTML of the ShadowRoot
with a bunch of DOM.
In Polymer, we said, hey,
let's just get rid of all that.
You don't have to
call those explicitly.
We're just going
to say, anything
you put inside of
your template, inside
of your elements
template, we're going
to create Shadow DOM from.
So by default, all
polymer-elements
use Shadow DOM.
Because we think the scoping
features and the composability
features that it gives you
are very, very powerful.
So let's walk through
an example of showing
you what composability means,
and also CSS and DOM scoping.
Right now, I have some
markup on the page here.
I have an image, my
profile image, an h2
and h3 for my title
and description,
and my Twitter handle.
So right now, we're not in
the world of Web Components
whatsoever.
We just have this markup,
just as it is on the page.
So let's first wrap this
thing in a Component.
We're going to create a
reusable Component somebody else
can just use.
We'll create a
profile-card element.
Inside of the
elements template, I'm
just going to drop in all
that markup that I had before.
So now this thing's
encapsulated in Shadow DOM.
And the way somebody
uses my element,
they declare a profile card.
And they get my name, and
my image, and my title.
And that's probably not
something they want.
So we can make this thing even
better and make it composable.
But the first thing
we need, nobody's
going to use our element
unless it's styled really cool
and looks great.
So I went to Michigan.
Go Blue, if anybody's out there
that went to Michigan, as well.
So I'm going to style my name
and my title as maize and blue.
So any time you put a
style tag or a style sheet
inside of your Shadow DOM,
it's scoped to that element.
So this is big, because it
means styles from the page
are not going to bleed in.
You can see the h2 and
h3 at the top of my slide
here is not affecting the way
my Component's h2 and h3 behave.
And you can see that my maize
and blue is not leaking out.
It's not changing the
two titles at the top.
So we have scoping of CSS.
This is really big.
The next thing we can do is add
a content div, add a wrapper.
Now, this might
not look that cool,
but it's actually
a really big deal.
The fact that we have DOM
scoping, we have a local DOM
tree, as encapsulated
by the Shadow DOM,
means that we can use
IDs again, willy-nilly.
They're not going to conflict
with the outside world.
ID info is a really
common ID, right?
But we can use class
names and IDs again
because it's local
to my Shadow DOM.
And the last thing
we can do is make
this thing more composable.
So what I've done
in this step is
I've actually removed the
markup from my Component.
And I'm saying, OK,
I want users to be
able to pass that data in to me.
I want them to be
able to configure
their own title and
their information.
So what I've done was
I've replaced that markup
with a content tag.
And a content tag is
called an insertion point.
And it basically
just says, hey, this
is a placeholder for rendering
stuff from the user's world
into my Shadow DOM world.
And so what it's
doing is actually
taking that h2,
h3, and the a tag,
and it's rendering it at that
location in the Shadow DOM.
Now, something else I've done
is I've leveraged Polymer's data
binding features.
So this profile card has
this attribute's image on it.
So it understands
an image attribute
when you put it on the
profile card image.
So I've kind of left
the image itself
as an implementation
detail of the Component.
But all users give to me is
just a string with an image.
It's super-easy to use.
Now, for anybody that's
paying attention,
you've noticed a
difference here,
between this step and this step.
I've lost my styling, right?
I've lost that maize and blue
that I worked so hard on.
And so what we
can do now is take
advantage of some of Shadow
DOM's new styling features.
So there's this
content pseudo-element.
And this says, hey,
if you're in h2
and you're going
through a content tag,
style yourself blue.
So that's how I can
regain those styles back.
The reason for the difference
is that my selectors in my style
DOM style sheet no longer affect
the stuff in the user line.
So I actually have to care
about that and bring that in.
Because they're logically
in a different place.
They're not part
of my local DOM.
So this is how we can get
composability and DOM scoping
and CSS scoping with Shadow DOM.
The last one of the four
Web Component standards
is HTML imports.
And what this brings is loading
and dependency management
to Web Components.
If you take an example
like Bootstrap today,
you have to do a bunch of
stuff to use Bootstrap.
So bootstrap.css.
You load the style sheet.
You're going to
load in a font icon.
JQuery is a dependency
that you have
to load in order to use
the widgets for Bootstrap.
You load, of course,
Bootstrap itself.
And then anything
that you're going
to use in order to put on
your page, all their widgets.
In the world of Web Components,
in the world of HTML imports,
this becomes a single line.
So we can wrap all that stuff
up in a single bootstrap.html
file, link rel="import".
And then that's how
somebody brings in Bootstrap
to their application.
Imports actually changes the
way we develop for the web.
Instead of going off and
finding API documentation
and piecing stuff together,
the first thing we can do
is say, hey, does
something else out there
exist that solves our problem?
We'll go off and find it.
Second is import it.
Once we have found something
that's useful to us,
let's import that
to our application.
And third is we
just use it, right?
We declare on our page
we're creating JavaScript.
And we just start
using the stuff.
So what do I mean by find?
You go up to a registry.
You go up to customelements.io.
You go up to Polymer's
catalog or some other catalog.
And you say, hey, I
want a core-toolbar.
I want to put a
toolbar on my page.
I want a core-icon-button,
for people
to be able to push
these awesome buttons.
So you use a tool like
bower, or something similar,
to install that and bring
that down to your application.
So you go off and
find something.
The next thing is
you use an import
to import it into your app.
In the head of your app,
you'll declare an HTML import
for a core-toolbar.
And you'll bring in
the core-icon-button,
as well, using import.
And the last step
is just to use it.
Right?
You just declare core-toolbar on
your page, once it's imported.
And this is a
composable element.
So it understands
core-icon-buttons.
It understands spans with
flex attributes on them.
And what you get is a toolbar.
No surprise there.
But it's really cool, right?
We're finding stuff.
We're finding stuff that's
reusable for our purposes.
We're using it.
We're bringing it in,
using HTML imports.
Imports are cool.
Imports are really cool.
So they give us a way to
bundle related JavaScript, CSS,
and HTML.
So a lot of people say,
hey, what about RequireJS?
Or what about ES6
Module Loaders,
or something like that?
And those are all really
awesome technologies.
But right now, if we want to
use JavaScript, HTML, and CSS,
we're going to be writing
Web Components that do that.
We need a way to load
all those resources,
those different
types of resources,
together, in a single URL.
And that's what, really,
HTML imports is all about.
It can also be used for
dependency management.
So the way Polymer kind
of uses HTML imports
is exactly like
the native stuff.
Exactly like the vanilla
Web Component stuff.
So typically, what
we do is we say,
hey, if you're creating an
element, put that in a file.
Put that in its own file.
Call it menu-bar.html.
And inside of that, you're
going to define your element.
So at the top of
the file, you're
going to actually
use imports to load
in the dependencies
for your element.
So we're creating a
polymer-element here.
That's the implementation
of this element,
this menu-bar element.
So we'll load polymer.html
as a dependency.
We're going to load the
paper-tabs and paper-tab
element as a dependency.
Because we're using those inside
of our own Custom Element.
You declare your element
using polymer-element.
And then the way somebody
uses your stuff is, again,
they just declare
a link rel="import"
to the menu bar file
that you've created.
And it's that easy.
So you can have imports that
reference other imports,
and it becomes a
dependency management.
So that's a little bit about
the four main specifications
of Web Components.
Now I'm going to switch
gears and talk to you
and start getting people
thinking in Web Components.
The first is that we
have to actually think
about what HTML even means.
What does it do?
So a lot of people see
HTML, and they say, hey,
there's all this
visual stuff, right?
This is stuff that
renders to the browser.
Your select tag.
Your progress tag.
A button, right?
It has these amazing controls.
You can declare an
audio tag on the page.
And you have all
these amazing controls
wrapped up inside of Shadow DOM.
That's the UI side.
But there's a whole
other side, which
is the non-visual elements.
And Matt talked about
this a little bit before.
But I really want to
drive home this point,
because it's important.
The non-visual elements
provide utility.
They do something, right?
They exist there for a reason.
But they don't actually
render anything.
So two of my favorite examples
are the style and script tag.
If you put text
inside of a style tag,
somehow the browser
knows to throw that off
to the CSS engine
and use that for CSS.
If you put text instead
of a script tag,
somehow the browser knows
to throw that one off
into the JavaScript engine and
interpret that as JavaScript.
I talked about template, right?
Template's a new tag that
we get with Web Components.
What you put inside of the
template is meaningful.
And it does something
interesting with that content.
But it doesn't actually
display anything.
In the world of Custom Elements,
we have the exact same thing.
So Polymer has its set of
core, non-visual elements--
things for loading libraries,
and working with local storage,
and doing things like selection.
We have a set of
visual elements.
So these are things like, hey,
I need an infinite scroll list.
I need a scaffold for
my mobile application,
or a toolbar, or an icon.
We have the highly visual
and highly interactive
material elements
that Rob Dodson
is going to talk about
more to you in a bit.
But I just want to show these.
These are actually
really awesome.
They have all these
really great effects.
You just declare these
on your page, and you go.
They're responsive.
They're accessible.
This one's really fun, because
it's got a little penny guy.
Whee.
So you get shadows.
You get effects.
The input's really cool.
A lot of people think Shadow DOM
is this encapsulated security
boundary, like Matt said.
I just want to point out
that using Shadow DOM styling
features, you can
actually drill in.
If we have a theme that we
want to apply these elements,
or these Components, you can
do that using Shadow DOM.
So now I've gone to Batman mode.
So all of my ink affects are
now these awesome orange.
And everything is kind
of fitting the look
and feel that I desire.
So that's just using Shadow
DOM styling features.
When thinking
Components, we actually
have to think about how we
interact with APIs, libraries,
and services again.
So what I mean by
this is if you take
the example of Google Maps.
Google Maps is one
of my favorite APIs.
It's very rich.
And you can do a lot of
interesting things with it.
The hello, world for
just throwing a marker
at the current user's
location, onto a map,
is actually a bit of
a boilerplate code
that you have to write.
So a little bit of CSS.
You have to have
a map container.
You have to load the
JavaScript library.
You have to do geolocation
to get the current user's
location.
Add a marker.
Add an eventListener
for the Info window.
You have to wait for the
map ready callback to fire.
Duh-duh-dzz.
It's actually a
lot of stuff, just
to render a marker to the map.
It's a lot of stuff.
In the world of Web Components,
this becomes a single tag.
I'm going to switch over here.
[APPLAUSE]
A single tag that doesn't
actually render a map.
[LAUGHTER]
Hold your horses.
A-ha.
So you declare the Google
map element on your tag.
And voila, you get a map,
exactly as you expect, right?
You don't have to know to
style the map using CSS.
You don't have to
have a div container.
load the library.
You just compose
it on your page,
and you're off to the races.
Super declarative.
Maps is a really rich API.
It has things that
are valuable to us,
like centering the map using
a latitude and longitude.
In the world of
Web Components, we
can expose that functionality
of that Library API
as a declarative
attribute on the element.
So I can center the map.
I can center this map using
a latitude and longitude
attribute.
I can set its zoom level
using an attribute.
And underneath, the
implementation of this
is totally transparent to me.
But it's calling the
Maps API under the hood.
But as a user of this
element, as a Component,
I don't care about that, right?
I just care about
declaring this.
And I get a map.
Exactly what I want.
We can make this
element composable,
using Shadow DOM
Custom Elements.
Inside of the
google-map tag, I can
put google-map-marker elements.
And those are meaningful
to this map tag.
So if you put those
inside of this tag,
it renders a marker to the
map, exactly as you'd expect.
The other cool
thing about this is
I'm reusing parts of
the platform that exist.
Again, since I'm tied in to
HTML, since I'm tied in to DOM,
I don't have to reinvent
the title attribute.
And you can see the
marker, it says, "Home."
I don't have to reinvent
the HTML5 drag-and-drop API.
If I call draggable="true"
in my element,
the underlying Maps API call
is made to make that element
draggable.
I can make the map
marker itself composable.
So if I put stuff inside of it,
if I put an h2 in an image tag,
that can be part of the
Info window for the marker.
And so that's what this element
does with that information.
So this thing is now
growing as an application,
just by composing the
elements together.
Another really common thing to
do in the Maps API is say, hey,
I want to fit all of
the markers on screen
that I have on my map.
And so you have to know a little
bit of JavaScript to do that.
You have to loop through
all of your map markers
and set the bounding
box on them.
In the world of
Web Components, we
can expose that API call
as a single attribute,
the fittomarkers
attribute on this tag.
And when you have that, any
time you add an extra element
to the map, the map just
knows, under the hood,
to set the right zoom level.
So this is really cool, right?
That application's
entirely readable.
This is an awesome
future of using
Web Components with
libraries and services.
If you care about
the example I showed
before, I didn't actually
show you the Geolocation
API in that last step.
This is the world of Polymer,
using the same example.
Instead of all that
boilerplate code,
it simply drops down to
a couple of elements.
And we're using Polymer's
data binding feature here,
to tie in all the latitude
and longitudes together.
And I can tie-in a paper-slider
element to set the zoom level
and zoom this map.
So there's no JavaScript
that this is running.
It's literally just
declaratively tying
these things together.
Google has 250 plus APIs.
That's crazy.
It's crazy awesome.
So we've been actually
thinking, on the Polymer team,
how do we bring the best
of Google's awesome sauce
to the world, this
declarative, amazing world
of web development using Web
Components, and vice versa?
So we actually started
a project on GitHub.
If you want to check it out,
googlewebcomponents.github.io.
There's a lot of really
cool things here.
So we have Components for
things like Google Maps,
working with Google
Spreadsheets,
working with OAuth,
doing Street View.
We have a component
for Analytics
that allows you to declaratively
create a dashboard,
just by declaring a
couple Analytics charts.
Awesome.
We have an element for creating
Google Cloud Compute VM
instances in the Cloud.
You declare this
element on your page.
And you create a VM
instance in the Cloud.
It's crazy awesome.
But it shows you the
power of this stuff.
This collection is growing.
It's probably buggy.
Feel free to submit
pull requests
and ask for more Components.
We're happy to take them.
So do we need Web Components?
Yes.
We need Web Components.
Web Components are totally cool.
I hope by now you've seen, sort
of, where this stuff is going.
They bring a lot to the table.
So productivity, we
can be productive.
We can rapidly
develop stuff, just
by reusing what somebody
else has built for us
and iterating on top of that.
We can be declarative, right?
Just declare stuff
on your page and go.
Markup is meaningful, again.
It's composable.
So we can compose applications
using smaller chunks,
using Shadow DOM.
It's maintainable.
This is big.
I can read Gmail source
one day and actually know
what's going on just
by reading that stuff.
It's reusable.
I can find, I can import,
and I can use an element
and just reuse it in my app.
Extensible.
Right?
We have a common way now,
with Custom Elements,
to extend Components.
Other people's stuff.
Or extend what the
platform gives us,
like an h1 tag, or a div tag.
Scoping.
This is a really big
one for Shadow DOM.
What Shadow DOM brings to the
table is DOM and CSS scoping.
Our styles don't leak out.
Our DOM is all local.
And it's a per-element API.
So Custom Elements.
You're defining
your Elements API.
The prototype, the
JavaScript-- all that stuff
goes just on the element.
It doesn't leak into
this global world.
It's interoperable.
We're at the browser's
lowest level, which is DOM.
And you get access
for the tools.
And the last one
is accessibility,
which is on by default.
So before I leave
you guys, I want
to leave you with this quote,
this awesome quote by Dimitri,
again.
He said that, "Custom
Elements is a bedrock API.
We should be able to build
all HTML elements with it."
So that's crazy.
Can we build all of HTML
with the technologies
that we're adding to the
platform for Web Components?
The answer is yes.
We can get very far.
So over a holiday
break, I actually
experimented with this.
I implemented the select
element using Polymer and Web
Components, using Shadow
DOM styling features,
using encapsulation,
DOM scoping.
And you can see the Polymer
version at the top here.
I don't want to bump it
up, because it'll totally
mess it up.
So you can see the
Shadow DOM, right?
You can have a little overlay,
and it behaves exactly
like the native
version of select,
which is this little overlay.
You could select
different properties.
You can change the multiple
attribute on this element.
And it has multi-select now.
Right?
So the really cool
thing about this
is you can't tell the
difference between the two.
Right?
We can implement HTML using
the low-level primitives
that the Web Component
APIs give us.
That's what I wanted to show.
So my question to you, my
thought experiment to you,
is, hey, what if the entire web
platform was hosted on GitHub?
What if the browser didn't
ship all these native tags
by default?
What if you had to go find,
import, and use those tags?
Bring them in using
bower and other tools?
And you said, hey,
I want to use an h1.
I'll go off and get that.
I want to use a marquee tag.
I want to go get that.
Maybe not a marquee tag, but.
This is a really kind of cool
and mind-bending experiment.
But there actually is
some folks on GitHub
who are experimenting with this.
They're seeing, can we implement
all of HTML's cool stuff,
using just the primitives
of Web Components?
It's really amazing stuff.
So if you want to know
more about Polymer,
you want to learn more
about Web Components,
check out polymer-project.org.
There's a lot of great
tutorials and information there.
[MUSIC - TEGAN AND SARA
AND THE LONELY ISLAND,
"EVERYTHING IS AWESOME!!!"]
Components are the
building blocks.
So I implore you to
go off and try them.
Please don't get left behind.
This is a fundamental
shift for web development.
It's a really exciting one.
It's a great time to
be a web developer.
It's a bullet train, too,
so it's speeding away.
So make sure you're on that.
Feel free to give me feedback
on this presentation.
I really thank you
guys for your time.
The presentation is
up at this URL here.
And if you want to tweet at
me or see the code on GitHub,
those links are there, too.